Hi, and welcome to the Neil
Ashton Podcast.
In each episode, we explained
some of the fascinating ways
that science and engineering are
changing the world around us.
We talked to leading engineers
from elite level sports like
cycling and Formula One to some
of the world's top academics to
understand how fluid dynamics,
machine learning, supercomputing
are bringing in a new era of
discovery.
We also hear some of their life
stories, their career advice,
the lessons they've learned on
the way that I hope will be
helpful to you too.
So sit back and enjoy this
episode.
Hi, and welcome back to the new
Ashton podcast today.
I think it's a pretty special
episode.
It's with really one of the
icons of CFD, Professor Ansi
Jamieson.
It really is somebody who I'd
always known about, you know,
from the early days of me
studying CFD and speaking to
various people, it was clear
that he was somebody who was a
real pioneer.
But I have to completely confess
that I was I was learning a lot
through the conversation I had
with him.
And as I was going through it, I
was blown away by what he has
done and what what it has led to
it.
It's pretty incredible that he
was there at the beginning of
both the use of computational
fluid dynamics, but also the
early days of computing, the
early days of really the
aeronautics, aeronautics, the
move to transonic, the sort of
evolution in aircraft design.
And IT it's amazing.
And I purposely have released it
today, which is his 90th
birthday.
And so I consider this an
episode to really celebrate the
life and career of Professor
Anthony Jameson.
Just very briefly to summarize,
he had incredible back story
going into the British Army,
being an officer in the British
Army, living around the world in
India, Malaya, studying at
Cambridge, then moving over to
to the US, working with some of
the defense companies and
aerospace companies, writing
code, then moving to become a
professor in New York, then
eventually going to Princeton.
But really the overall and later
then he went to Stanford and
he's now at Texas A&M.
But what blows my mind is one,
his intellect, he's just the way
you can hear and speak about
things.
But also the fact that when you
appreciate what he was writing
these codes decades before any
of the codes that we today take
for granted, the commercial
codes, the government codes.
And you really can see that it,
it really, I, I don't think it's
too far of a stretch of
imagination to say he was one of
the key people that is
responsible for modern day CFD.
There's not many people who can
say that it's, it's incredible.
And yeah, he, he's known for
certain certain things, you
know, like adjoint methods,
maybe for aircraft design or
the, or some of the, the JST
scheme shock capturing.
But I think that that culture of
writing the code, getting in, in
the very early days, working
with industry closely, he was
not a pure academic nor a pure
industry.
It was clear that he was always
moving between and you know, as
we discussed a little bit, but
probably didn't focus on too
much.
Just the sheer number of people
that he has supervised and
mentored who have gone on to do
amazing things as top professors
and and engineers throughout the
world is a real testament to
what he has done.
Now this is a completely
unedited, this is a more than
two hour long conversation and I
purposely kept it this way to
not take anything away from what
his his life story is.
There was far many more things
we could have spoken about but I
wanted to be respectful of of
his time.
I will put some links in into
the chat.
If you're watching this on, on
YouTube, it's probably one that
maybe will take you a few times
to go through because, you know,
like I said, it's more than two
hours long.
But yeah, I, I just have
incredible honour of being able
to, to speak to him.
And I want to thank him.
And hopefully I can say that on
behalf of everybody else to
thank him for his amazing
contribution to the field of
computational fluid dynamics,
computational aerodynamics and
scientific computing.
So sit back and enjoy this
episode with Professor Anthony
Jameson.
So, so where did it, where did
it all all begin?
So did you have, were you one of
these children who were always
into aircraft from a very young
age, or was this something that
that took age?
How did this love of aircraft
and and later fluid dynamics
begin?
Well, so actually there's more
boys.
So I can tell you the following
story, and of course it's just
my memory, but my father was a
British Army officer, so I think
he was sent to India in 1938
when I was three years old, and
he spent six months in Bombay.
But then he was attached to the
headquarters of the British
Army.
Remember, there was an Indian
army, but there was also
contingents of the British Army
in India.
So the headquarters is in Delhi.
But because Delhi is very hot
during the summer, they moved to
this summer.
Capital similar, which is at
foothills of the similarities at
7000 feet.
So somewhere around when I was
perhaps I've also had a nanny at
this point and she took my
brother and me.
I have a brother who was one
year younger than me, but born
on the same day as me.
On a walk in Delhi.
We went past a small airport,
which I'm sure doesn't exist
anymore, and there was a, a
biplane there, a twin engined
biplane, something like a
Vicar's Valletta if you want,
but I don't know exactly what it
was.
But it had by playing with
sticks and strings all over the
place and the engines in the
middle of each, between each
pair of wings.
I looked at that and you know, I
had been looking at birds quite
a bit and I thought this is all
wrong.
You know, birds don't have all
these wires and sticks and
things.
But then it took another look
and I was looking at, I saw it
had these movable hinge surfaces
on the wings and on the tail.
And I looked at the tail and saw
that if you, I saw the wind
bearing over the plane.
I can't tell you why, but I saw
that if you push the elevator
up, that the wind would hit the
top of the elevator and push the
tail down.
And that was my first time I'd
ever really had a close view of
an aircraft.
Well, I can't have been more
than about six years old because
soon after that my father was
sent to Iraq and my mother spent
moved to similar on a full time
basis.
And we lived in similar for the
next between 1940 and 43.
So my mother taught me to read
and write by copying over her
handwriting.
She started teaching me the
tables when I was about 7 and I
told her that you don't need to
teach me this because I can work
it out.
It's fairly obvious to me that
you can, you know, 7 + 7 to 14
and add 7 again, it's 21.
I can do that.
So at that point, my mother used
to read to us.
I haven't yet gone to school.
I went to school when I was 7
when my mother got pregnant at
this Roman Catholic mission
school in similar, but I found
an observer's sort of aircraft
spotting work with three view
silhouettes of things like
Spitfires and Measure Schmidt
109 and so on.
And I persuaded my mother to buy
this book for me and I forced
her to read out of this book
more or less everyday sort of
wingspan, 36 feet and things
like that.
So that was that.
All right.
But we did.
My father was spread first Iraq
and then Iran and then he was
moved back to fund against
Japan, which by that time was in
the not in Burma but in the
North East of India.
So when I was eight we moved to
the Shalom NE of India and I
went to another of these Roman
Catholic mission schools for a
year.
My dad wanted to have something
to do with the invasion of
Normandy and he applied to come
back to England.
So we came back to England in
March 1944, coming on a convoy
that went through the
Mediterranean and then went way
out into the Atlantic and
finally landed in Liverpool on a
horrible cold day and they
managed to get into luggage vans
or some train we travelled to
some.
My father's sister was living in
Sherborne at the time when we
spent a few weeks there.
And then I was dumped in a
boarding school, a boarding prep
school.
And the reason for that
particular school was that my
father actually had been a
Wimbledon tennis player and also
one of the world's best squash
players.
And the owner of the school was
somebody else who had been on
the British national squash team
that toured America in 1934.
As far as I can make out, I was
actually conceived in America
during that squash tour.
Anyway, I went to this boarding
prep school that would normally
be in Brighton, but it was
evacuated to the Midlands during
the war and well, we had I was
put in the third form.
It had 6 forms, so I was nine.
I was put in the third form.
But what happened was that you
could be promoted each term.
And each term I came in the top
five and got promoted.
So by the time I was 10, I was
actually sitting in the top form
of this school.
And I sat there for the next
couple of years kind of without
much to do because the teachers
there, I mean, these are during
the war and they were not the
only people available to teach,
were sort of retirees and so on.
I think that somebody, for
example, could have built me
calculus at this point, but
there was nobody at the school
who probably knew calculus and
then wound up in 1940.
Seven, my father applied to a
job in New York for the what was
going to be the United Nations
Army, which never happened
because of the Cold War.
The reason it did is that my
mother was actually born in
America and we had American
families.
So they went to America and they
left my brother and me going to
these boarding schools in
England.
And we spent our school holidays
with an aunt, actually.
And I wound up getting a
scholarship to Winchester in
1948.
And so that kind of had a big
impact on me.
I spent in Winchester courses
probably about that time
considered to be the best
academic school in England
probably.
And at Winchester, I wound up
focusing more on physics and
chemistry, but I wound up
eventually getting a scholarship
to Cambridge.
Well, we had state scholarships
and county scholarships, but I
also took this open scholarship
exam in Cambridge.
I went to Trinity Hall because
my father had actually been sent
to Cambridge for two years as an
Army officer, but asked him what
college he was, he said Trinity.
And somebody at the War Office
didn't know that Trinity Hall
and Trinity were two different
colleges.
Said he he went to Chinterley
Hall.
Sorry, decided I might as well
go to the same place.
But I didn't go straight to
Cambridge.
See, we had national service in
those days, so out of Winchester
I went straight from the Army
for two years when I was 18.
And so now there's something
else that's a little bit
relevant to this.
While I was at Winchester, one
of the maths teachers was Doctor
Thwaites.
Thwaites actually was a quite
well known expert in theoretical
aerodynamics and he he went on
from Winchester to become the
chair of aeronautics at
Southampton University.
Now I was never in a class
taught by him, but he organised
some trip to visit Super Marine
in South outside Southampton,
which is pretty near Winchester.
And I told him I was really
interested in aircraft.
And he told me that I ought to
read the book by Claret Airfoil
and Air School Theory, which I
don't know whether you're
familiar with that book or not.
So I managed to to get a copy,
I'm not quite sure how.
So now when I'm in the Army, I
spent several months in basic
training and then I passed this
War Office selection board for
officer training.
So another six months on officer
training, then you could apply
to go where you want.
And I applied to go to, to
Malaya was then called now
called Malaysia, right?
So we went out to Malaysia,
Malaya by ship.
And I had this book by glass.
I read it on the ship and I've
still got that copy of the book
in very tattered form.
And you can see that I've put
handwritten notes all over the
place when I tried to verify the
formulas.
But this, this book actually
introduces complex variables and
conformal mapping.
So I actually learnt complex
variables from this book and
also conformal mapping.
I've also learnt 3D lifting line
wing theory of Prantle.
So now I spend the year as a
Lieutenant in Malaya and I came
back and my father by this time
was back in England and he knew
somebody rather who had a
contact with Bristol Aero
Engines.
So I spent six months from March
to September working at Bristol
Aero Engines before going to
Cambridge.
So I was in a compressor
designed section, about 50
people and everybody else in
there had a university degree.
But anyway, the first day or two
somebody showed me like it was a
side rule.
We didn't.
This is before electronic
computing had really come in and
I went to a book.
I bought a book on
thermodynamics and another one
on jet engines and read them in
a hurry.
As it turned out, I could do the
job.
I didn't didn't need a
university degree.
Then the next thing that
happened was that we were
supposed to do these stage by
stage calculations as slide
rules looking at data from this
Tess station which had like
25,000 horsepower electric
motors driving this and the test
station blew up.
Well, the suddenly got out of
balance and everything just torn
apart.
So there was no data.
So it was the sort of stroke of
that for me because then they
had to think of something else
for me to do and I looked at
something called radial
equilibrium that flows in jet
engine compressors.
And then finally I actually
calculated the they were testing
or had the 1st 2 spool jet
engine to superstore the Olympus
that went in the Valcon and
later was adapted to the
Concorde.
And they had flight test data
and they didn't know what the
relative speed of the two high
speed, high pressure and low
pressure compressors would be.
So based on the flight
measurements of the RPM, I
calculated the combined
compressor characteristic for
the whole 2 spools.
So that's before I got to
Cambridge.
Before, yeah, yeah, before you
went to university.
All right.
But by the time I got to
Cambridge, of course I knew
quite a bit of basic
aerodynamics, like I also knew
quite a bit about
thermodynamics.
I know at Cambridge I wasn't
sure whether to try maths or
physics or engineering, but
seemed like the path of minimum
effort was to do what we called
mechanical sciences.
At Cambridge.
When you take, if you have a
scholarship, you could take
what's called a fast course
admit you take the secondary
exams the end of your first year
and basically your degree exam
after two years and then.
The first third year you do
something wants to be a kind of
post graduation, sort of like
approximately a master's degree.
But but at Cambridge I was
really, I thought they weren't
teaching the maths that we
needed, so they didn't teach
factor analysis, for example.
And so I started buying, they
were various quite inexpensive
books and I started buying these
books on things like vector
analysis and tensor analysis and
so on and trying to teach myself
anyway, I.
Were you always a more than
maths person than an
engineering?
Did you?
Did you always have a a keenness
for maths?
You know, in your earlier years
you said then that they didn't
teach enough maths.
Do you, do you have a very
mathematical brain?
Do you find maths comes very
naturally?
Well, yes, I think it does, but
I didn't read maths at Cambridge
and maybe I should have it
actually I have a younger
brother who but actually eight
years younger than me and he did
read maths at Cambridge.
And so anyway, I but yeah, I'm
really interested in, well, for
example, I mean for the Greeks,
you know, people think about
Pythagoras theorem.
But the thing that's actually
interesting to me is a
consequence of Pythagoras
theorem is that if you have a
triangle with two sides of one,
I mean right triangle, then the
length of third side of sqrt 2
and now there's no fraction that
when you square it can produce
2.
So you can prove that however
large the fraction is.
And the Greeks already knew this
and it really wasn't sorted out
until the 19th century when it
had a theory for real numbers
developed.
Another kind of interesting
thing is that Euclid, he's known
for his geometry, but he
actually had a proof that
there's no largest prime number.
So they knew there was an
infinite number of primes
already, the Greeks.
So this is not the kind of
question that people designing
aeroplanes really usually
interested in.
But I am interested in this kind
of thing, and there's certainly,
which basically the theory of
what's progressively larger
infinities.
There's countable numbers and
then there's the real numbers
and so on.
There's a theorem that the set
of all subsets is larger than
the original set, which means it
could get a whole hierarchy of
these transfinite numbers.
So yeah, this kind of thing
continuous to interest me, but I
was also still interested in
aircraft and I was very lucky in
the following sense that in
England in those days, well
under the Labour government,
they tried to make
opportunities, firstly for
people to get into universities.
But secondly, if you got first
class honours, your degree
exams, you automatically got
support from the Ministry of
Education to do doctoral studies
so that she would pay the full
tuition and lodging to any
university who was willing to
accept you as a graduate
student.
So of course I was able to take
advantage of that, but I didn't
really want to to leave
Cambridge.
So I had to try to find somebody
inside Cambridge who doing
something that interested me.
And I wound up finding Arthur
Shurcliffe, who later became
well known kind of the world,
society and so on.
But at the time I knew he was
only 7 years older than me and
had just been made in a lecture.
He was doing Magneto
hydrodynamics.
So that's what I wound up doing
in my thesis.
But and then about one year into
the thesis, I was lucky that I
was in kind of invited to apply
for what's called a research
fellowship at Trinity Hall.
So research fellows at Oxford or
Cambridge are people who are
actually are on the governing
bodies of their colleagues.
I mean, it's a sort of pseudo
faculty kind of position.
So I had three fellowship at
Trinity Hall.
Actually I had a slightly
difficult start because I had
been getting my grant from the
Ministry of Education every
three months and that was paid
in advance.
And then as a researcher it
turned out that I was going to
get paid quarterly, but in
arrears.
So I had like six months and I
had to ask the advisor of the
college to to give me a loan
because I, I.
So the other thing is that my
advisor, Arthur Shurcliffe, so
he went on an exchange to MIT my
third year as a doctoral
student.
So at this point a student who
was one year ahead of me became
my nominal thesis advisor and I
had actually did experimental
thesis and tried to generate
alphane waves in a liquid
sodium.
My thesis by the way you can
find on my Stanford homepage of
I wound up building A10 tonne
magnet and things like that and
we needed 300 amperes of
current, 200 volts.
And there was a motor generator
set from a World War and
submergine in the lobby of the
engineering department.
And I managed to have that moved
into the lab and use that to
supply the current for this
magnet.
I sort of after all this I
realised firstly I did not think
I should be doing experiments.
I don't feel very uncomfortable
trying to interpret sort of
pictures and the sue escapes.
I didn't actually think Magneto
hydrodynamics is going anywhere
in engineering, so I didn't
really know what I wanted to do.
And then I had some sort of
interest in politics.
I was quite upset when Macmillan
stepped down as Prime Minister
and engineered this Lord Hume
becoming Prime Minister and I
thought, well, maybe I should
get involved.
The trade student in Congress
advertised at the time for
people to work in the economics
department, and I sent you the
an application and they decided
they would interview me.
So I had about 3 weeks to read
as much as I could about
economics in a hurry.
And then I had an interview with
Len Murray, who at that time was
head of the economics department
but later became general
secretary.
He wound up hurrying me as an
economist working for the Trade
Union Congress, and it was quite
interesting actually.
They had what they called
National Economic Development
Council Nettie's, which were 1/3
government, 1/3 management from
industry and 1/3 union reps was
supposed to be discussing how to
improve things, different
industries.
So I was actually preparing the
position for the trades unions
on the aircraft industry and the
electrical industry, but I knew
that I wasn't going to be long
term a trade union person.
I found it, it was interesting
and actually I did a kind of
study of what happened to rates
of inflation versus unemployment
and going back to about 1900 and
I found that interesting enough
the fastest rate of inflation in
England was usually on the
downside of each economic cycle.
And that's because as far as I
can make out costs went up on
the downside because there was
less utilisation of the
factories and so on and
companies has passed the higher
cost straight on high prices.
I've certainly concluded that
this idea that there's a sort of
non inflationary rate of
unemployment is is wrong and
actually morally wrong as well
as practically wrong in my
opinion.
I mean you deliberately a high
rate of unemployment in order to
prevent inflation is actually
sort of a bit like human
sacrifice used to be a sort of
be historic good.
You know you sacrifice somebody
for the benefit of everybody
else right.
But anyway, quite by chance
there was an advancement in one
of the London Evening newspapers
saying that Orcas Sidley was
dynamics was trying to looking
for engineers and they would
have some representatives of the
company in a hotel.
Happened to me about 5 minutes
walk from the Trades Union
Congress.
So I decided I might as well
walk in there around about 5 in
the evening at the end of the
day and had a very weird
interview.
So there were two people in the
room.
Marathon said what do you think
I can do?
I said I think I can do
aerodynamics.
The other guy said well what are
you doing now?
I said, well, I'm working as an
economist.
So then there was complete
silence for about two minutes.
Then one of them said, well,
what makes you think you can do
aerodynamics?
I said, well, I have a PhD in
Magneto hydrodynamics and I
think it would be relatively
easy for me to do aerodynamics.
So they thought about that for a
bit.
They finally just said, well,
would am I interested in coming
to the factory, which is in
Warwick basically exactly what
used to be the Armstrong
Whitworth company during the
Second World War made some very
bad airplanes.
There was a bomber called the
Whitney sort of who knows down.
But anyway, I said, well, it
would depend on the salary.
They said they didn't know what
the salary would be.
I said, in that case I don't, I
don't know whether I'm
interested in coming for an
interview and I, I didn't
certainly hear from them again,
but but suddenly about a month
later they, they wrote to me and
asked me if they would go up
there.
So I found you travelled up for
about a couple more interviews
and the outcome was that they
decided to offer me a position
as chief mathematician of this
Hawkeye City dynamics in
Coventry.
So actually not reporting to the
head of aerodynamics, but on a
level or even above him.
So I thought, well, I got to try
this.
So I wound up in Hawkins City
Dynamics.
And.
And how old were you then?
Well, that was 1964, I guess.
So I was just coming up to SO.
You were 3030.
Just approaching that, yeah.
Yeah.
So actually incredible.
When I got to Orchestilla
Dynamics, the first thing that
happened was that the guy who
had kind of initiated hiring me,
head of aerodynamics, a guy
called Malcolm James, told me
that he decided to leave and was
going to work for Douglas
Aircraft in California.
So I had expected that I would
collaborate with him, and that
didn't happen.
You see it only overlapped a
couple of weeks, but I did, I
did quite a lot of antenna
calculations for example.
And again, if you go on my
homepage, you can find some
Hawker Sidley reports, which
kind of thing there was during
at the time.
And well, what I concluded was
after I'd been there about a
year was that they were never
actually going to build another
missile.
They were making anti aircraft
missiles and they had us, it's
called the C dot.
And I didn't think we were ever
going to build anything.
So I finally decided, well I've
either got to get out of the
aircraft industry or I have to
come to America, one or the
other because British aircraft
industry didn't seem to be going
to build anything anyway.
Every project got cancelled by
the government, sometimes even
when they got to the point of
flying.
So finally I had some interview
actually, I think with the
central that's just a generating
board and for some teaching
positions somewhere.
I'm so lucky I was turned down
by both of them.
But, and then I went on this, I
can't quite remember, but at
that time Boeing, Douglas and so
on were recruiting quite heavily
in in England.
Well, I knew that they had teams
in England and I wasn't
interviewed by Helberg or
Douglas.
And I probably thought I would
probably rule out because they
wouldn't like my trade union
background.
But only Drummond, who I didn't
know a great deal about, but
they made these sort of fatter
plants during the Second World
War.
They said that they were
interviewing in London and they
in fact decided to invite me to
an interview.
So I wound up hitting it off
rather well with the guy who
interviewed me, and he said,
well, would I like to be in what
department?
I said, well, the research
department at Grumman.
He said, well, he didn't
represent the research
department, but he could
recommend me to in one of the
aerodynamics or thermodynamics,
this kind of thing.
So I finally accepted an offer
to work in the aerodynamics
department of Grumman or Long
Island.
That didn't start very smoothly
the day I got there.
Well, firstly they had a kind of
outside the main Grumman sort of
campus.
They had this plant where people
who hadn't got security
clearances were parked.
So I went, I reported to this
department.
There was an Englishman in
charge who said he was very
sorry, but they didn't have any
free desk for me to sit at.
I mean, they had about 150
people in there sitting side by
side, but there was no free
desk.
So then they said, well, the
best thing to do is we'll send
you to to be interviewed by the
head of the aero department.
I mean, I had to be escorted by
a copy.
So I get to see this head of the
aero department and it was Bill
Murphy.
And his opening words were that
it was been a mistake to harm
him, that he didn't have any
need for anybody with a PhD,
that he had a summoned with a
PhD there before who was
arrogant and lazy, had no need
for me.
So this didn't seem like a very
good start.
But then he handed me off with
one of his group leaders, a guy
called Rudy Mayo, who So they
had control systems inside the
aerodynamics department, because
you have to be like a fighter.
Then the aerodynamic stability
depends a lot on things like
dihedral and so on.
So it's not just black boxes.
So Rudy Meyer, I met him and he
turned out to be an extremely
nice guy who was actually a
veteran of the Korean War.
And he said he thought we have
seen to look at Horowitz's
method of discerning control
systems or stability
augmentation systems that I, I
never heard of Horowitz.
So I sort of thought about it a
bit.
I counted, I said, look, I think
it's very interesting to look at
issue of control systems, but
why don't you let me go away and
do a little bit of research for
a few days and I'll come back
and make a recommendation.
So he he agreed to that.
Now I'm not quite sure how I
managed to find the literature,
but I mean, we haven't had quite
a good library.
I suppose they may have allowed
me into it.
But anyway, when I met Rudy the
following week, I suggested that
we try the new optimal control
theory.
At that time was quite new.
Pioneered by Kalman in
particular with favours from the
Kalman filter and really went
along with that.
So I started looking at how you
would apply linear optimal
control theory to designing
control systems for fighter
aircraft and such like or actual
fact.
Also, Graumman was building this
electronic warfare plane, the E2
area, the big radome on top of
it.
And so that had really awkward
stability characteristics you
could have had.
So the question was, could you
design something that would make
it flyable?
And what I actually got into was
that you don't necessarily
optimal control requires you to
measure everything.
I mean, it's fairly obvious
because you can't really have an
optimal control if you can't
predict the trajectory.
So if you express the system of
the 1st order system of
differential regulations, you
need to know the initial
conditions for each variable.
In other words, if it's a
feedback system, you need to
measure everything the full
state.
But actually to make a workable
control system, you don't
necessarily need that.
So you can try to make a what
would be in some sense a
suboptimal system nowadays, a
quarterback so-called sparse
control, where you restrict the
number of permitted feedbacks.
And actually for lateral control
of an airplane, for example, you
don't really want to measure the
rail angle because otherwise if
you rail 360°, the control
system will try to the whole way
back.
It doesn't recognise it.
All right, so nowadays, you
know, quite a mathematical
theory for sparse control, but I
wound up actually publishing
about 15 journal articles and
control theory over the next few
years.
Some other strikes of luck at
this point because so there was
a a scientist called John Dee
Young who was an ex NASA guy who
was developing a theory for
predicting very high lift
aerodynamics, what we call V
store aircraft.
It was a thing like the Brigade
941 that has his big propellers
and then it has flaps to try to
deflect the propeller slipstream
to take off in a very short
distance.
So John Deyoung had got a
contract from Nasser Ames to
develop this theory, and then he
was married to a Brazilian woman
who wasn't very happy,
apparently long.
He asked for a leave of absence
for three months and then he
didn't come back.
So Brahman got out message from
Nasr Ames saying what's happened
to the contract?
The Pi appears to be now working
for Ling Temco Fort, which the
government didn't know.
So now there's a crisis.
The head of aerodynamics said,
well, we should just give up on
the contract.
And he was overruled by the vice
president of engineering.
We said we can't tell NASA that
there's nobody else is able to
do it here.
At this point.
It turned out that having
someone with a PhD was a little
bit of an advantage that they
asked me if I was willing to
take over the contract.
I said, well, I don't really
want to, but we need to, as long
as I'm also allowed to continue
doing some work on this control
system theory.
So they agreed to that.
But now when I looked at the
youngster, I thought it was
actually not quite right.
But I came up with fixes and
kind of convinced the, I said,
well, we have to write a
computer, a curve also.
And the first reaction was that
that'll cost you much.
And I went out to NASA and said,
no, I can write this in within
the cost of this contract.
So that meant that at this point
I felt that I was being
underpaid by government because
I knew that people with my level
of experience were getting quite
a bit more by just by reading
the job advertisements that used
to come out in the Sunday
newspapers.
I wound up having an interview
with an outfit called General
Research based in Santa Barbara,
who were trying to develop a
anti ballistic missile system.
They offered me a job and my
first reaction was to say yes.
So I gave government notice on a
Friday and on Monday I was
called in before the VP of
engineering who said that he was
retrospectively raising my
salary by 30% from the beginning
of the year.
Would I reconsider?
So I said yes, but I don't
really want to dust your
dynamics.
I mean, I want to look at a
broader picture.
And finally, they created a
staff position for me where I
reported to the manager of
Flight Sciences, a man called
Stu Harvey.
Stu first asked me if I could
try to design AA wind tunnel
that Common might build.
I looked at this for a few
months.
I don't really believe that
Common is ever going to go
anywhere with it.
Well, then all of a sudden, and
this is in I guess like November
1969, Stu Harvey called in and
says that we've got to do
something about supercritical
wings.
And I said, well, what do you
mean by supercritical wing?
And he said, well, the wing that
works well in transonic flow.
And Wickham, at this point,
Archie Wickham and NASA Langley
had made a big splash with what
he called supercritical airfoils
that managed to reduce the shock
drag transonic.
And Wickham is experimentalist
who just sort of used a file to
change the shapes and so on.
And Stu Howie says, well, we
can't depend on Wickham's file.
So I said to Stu, well look,
this is actually very
interesting.
I said there's a aerospace
sciences meeting being held in
New York in January, and maybe I
should.
After all, Grumman's 40 miles
from New York City.
And I said maybe I should go to
this and try to find out what's
being done in transonics.
And I went to this meeting and
the whole moment presented what
became quite a famous paper on
calculating a solution to the
transonic small disturbance
equation.
And The thing is I knew very
well that transonic flow cannot
be treated by linearising
anything.
So you have linearised subsonic
equations called Prandtl Kraut
equation or you have linearised
supersonic flow.
But those what happens in
transonic flow is it it's
actually an elliptic equation in
the subsonic part of the
Fairfield and hyperbolic and
supersonic pattern.
You can indicate that change in
type and cheap hold on inner
equations.
And there were books, for
example by Otsochich and Ben
Bersen, attempts at analytic
solutions of transonic flow
basically gone no way.
So I knew that you had to do
this by some kind of numerical
calculation, and I also saw that
computers are getting just fast
enough that you actually
probably could do some useful
calculations.
So that was kind of my chance to
try to solve the problem.
This was a pivotal moment.
Just at the right time, down in
the right it.
Seems like you had, but you had
a build up.
I, I, I assumed that from an
early stage of your career that
you were working on transonic
flow, but you almost had 36
years of build up to this point
to then be given the opportunity
to, to focus on this.
Yeah, well, that's is it.
No, I hadn't actually worked in
Sonic at all, and I knew very
little about it, and I didn't
nothing much about numerical
methods.
I'd never taken a course in
numerical methods, but I had
learned how to solve partial
differential equations as part
of my thesis, because when I did
this semi magical hydrodynamics,
I had to solve this.
I solved the equations for these
alphane waves by separation of
variables and expansions and
Bessel functions and things like
that.
So I had some background in
Pdes.
I've never taken a course in
Pdes either.
But now that I realised that you
could do something numerically,
turned out that nobody, the head
of the aero department, grandma,
wasn't willing to put anybody on
to this.
I finally decided I'd better try
to do it myself, so I started
trying to write computer
programmes for fluid flow and I
didn't.
I knew I had to learn more about
numerical methods.
So I managed to get hold of a
book by Rick Meyer and Morton
called Find out Different
Methods for initial value
Problems and that was very hard
for me.
Talked things like Banach spaces
and so on.
I never heard of, but I fought
my way through this book.
And then what we needed to do
was not to solve the small
disturbance equation because
they're not small disturbances.
When you have a supercritical
airfoil will win.
So the best model was to use the
what's called the full transonic
potential flare equation.
I ruled out trying to solve the
Euler equations because you
didn't have enough memory on the
computer at the time.
Do a 3D, see the potential flow
solution.
You just got to store 1 variable
instead of like 5 variables if
you're solving the Euler
equations.
And so I could see that we could
actually write a repair game
that would work.
And in the meanwhile also I had
discovered that there was a
group at the Quran Institute led
by Paul Garabedian and I went in
to meet them.
Paul Garabedian had a student
called David Corn who they had
developed a method of
calculating so-called shock free
airfoils in transonic flow by
transformation to the photograph
plane and then a method of
solution so-called complex
characteristics.
It is new to Bulgaria, but I got
to know them and I thought that
we could solve the full
transformation flow equation,
but you would need to use some
kind of conformal mapping so as
to map the flow outside the
airfoil to the flow inside a
unit disk.
Well, that's I had the
background and conformal mapping
way back to the Clark book.
So I wrote a book Codes to solve
absolutely incompressible
Invisible Flow by conformal
mapping with.
My first step was flow one, but
I envisaged a sequence of codes
that would become progressively
more complicated, more
complicated geometries go to 3D
and so on, and eventually go to
solving the Euler equation.
So I in Fortune at the time you
were not allowed more than six
characters in a variable name or
a programme name.
So I truncated FLOW to Flo to
allow for three digits.
And after, about, about sometime
during 1971 or after, I managed
to get a flow solver for
transonic potential flow
working.
And at this point, Paul Garabin,
I had persuaded grandma to hire
Corn as a consultant.
So we had some contacts and
they'd also been writing an
analysis code.
And when they found out that I'd
read mine, that appeared to work
as well.
Paul asked me if I would spend 3
months at the Quran Institute as
a visitor and I thought I said
yes.
I got, I, I realised that I'm
not going to be able to do this
in the long run at Grameen.
So I had to be considered moving
into academia somehow.
And so I went there for three
months and then Paul kind of
tested me in various ways during
that time.
And then he said, well, why
don't you stay here?
And he said, well, I can't just
disappear from grammar and I
have to go back and give them
notice.
But I agreed and he had me as a
senior research scientist.
That's in 1972.
And he told me that there's no
faculty positions going to be
available at the Quran
Institute, but if you make us
flat, you might get an offer
from somewhere else.
So I said, OK, I'll settle for
that.
So when I got to the Quran
Institute started working for
Paul who he agreed that I would
try to write a 3D solver for the
transonic potential flow, but he
wanted it to be for a yard
flying wing because he had a
contract with Archie Jones at
Nassau Ames.
Archie Jones is advocating that
supersonic transport aircraft to
adjust a flying wing which would
fly at a skew angle, so-called
yard flying wing.
Of course, that never actually
happened, but but the meanwhile
also had a contract with NASA
Langley because Whitcomb also
understood that if you could
calculate transonic flows, it
might help him to obtain better
supercritical airfoils.
So I wound up being the point of
contact of both Archie Jones and
Nasser Ames and Archie Whitcomb
and Langley.
And both of them sort of
encouraged me.
They, they said move, Jameson
move.
But that's so that maybe I could
take this further.
So then another thing that
happened was that I'd only been
at the Quran Institute a week
when they they had a they
didn't, they didn't take
teaching very seriously there.
But what they did do is they
teach a lot of courses in the
evenings because they were
accommodating people who were
working in the city who wanted
to study nights.
Turned out that the graduate
numerical analysis course was
normally taught by Isaacson,
who's a co-author of the book
Isaacson and Keller, which is
quite famous.
And Isaacson was on leave and
they hadn't got an instructor.
So they asked me if I would like
to try to teach it.
So I said yes, I can try.
That was that in some sense is a
circle that for me, because I
didn't know really numerical
methods other than the book I
mentioned I'd read by Morton
Rickman, but I had to teach some
Isaacs and in Keller it really
mean I had to read the book
ahead of the class.
But the standby time I've done
that, I mean, they're pretty
thorough knowledge of numerical
methods.
So then after two years, the
maths department at UCLA was
interested.
I got an approach and well, they
turned out that they were really
bored in trying to hire Paul
Garabinia, but it was the kind
of suggestion that they would
hire both of us and they offered
me full professorship at UCLA,
but never in writing.
But that's what was on the table
at this point.
Quran Institute decided to
respond by eventually the first
offering me an associate
professor.
I said no, I'll take the full
professor at UCLA.
So then they did offer me a full
professor said turn it kind of
just like that.
So I've never been in a an
assistant professor or an
associate professor went
straight from the yes.
Straight to the top.
So after that I was no longer
working directly for Paul
Garrabedian, but of course he
remained in close contact and I
went on to he'd.
Actually another thing that
happened was just before I got
that offer, I had written this
Flow 17 which did a
three-dimensional flow plasters
yard wing.
But I knew perfectly well that
Craft engine was never going to
build a yard ring that they
needed was a swept ring code.
So Paul had another visitor from
McDonald, Ludlow said we have a
guy called John Darlene, John
Raj who said we need a swept
ring coated and our cell code.
I said yes, I know that.
I said, look, I can write the
codes for you if you'll help me
debug them.
So I wrote the two codes.
Flow 21 was for Nacelle and Flow
22 was for Swept Wing.
In a few weeks, actually.
Each was a box of cards.
You know, we were still using
card readers.
We had this control letter 6600,
which was kind of the world's
fastest computer at the time.
That's because Quran had all
these contacts with people like
Von Norman and it had the
so-called computer centre in
Quran Institute who would get
the latest computers.
But the 6600 was fast but stands
to the day.
But it only had 130,000 words in
memory.
That turns out to be 64 bit
words, turns out to be about 2
megabytes.
So you couldn't really do a 3D
calculation and store it on the
core memory.
You had to go plane by plane
reading off the disk.
Anyway, I So I wrote the two
codes and then John and myself
went to see Borgara Billion and
he was furiously angry.
He said I was supposed to be
helping him write his book on
simply good wing sections and I
was only interested in being
famous and so on.
And I said, well yes, I'd
certainly like to be famous, but
actually I really need a threat
to encourage me.
But John Darlene was not.
After that, John Darlene felt he
couldn't whisk confronting Paul
and trying to debug his codes or
help me.
And so he I decided perhaps
you'd better leave it alone for
the moment.
So the two boxes of cards
remained on the floor of my
office at the Grown Institute
for the next few months.
I never tried to run either of
them.
And then when John went back to
Douglas, he told them that these
two codes existed but hadn't
been debugged.
And then I got a call from a
guy, David Curie, who was
working for the McDonnell
Douglas Research Centre in Saint
Louis, saying that they had
somebody coming for the summer
and would it be possible for
them to have this guy see if he
can debug Flow 21.
So I said that's fine.
And I flew out to Saint Louis
through the box of cards, flew
to one and gave it to Lewin.
Well, this guy did nothing that
summer.
But then in fall of 74, David
Coe was suddenly offered a
position as a visiting assistant
professor at Cornell.
They'd had a crisis because two
of their top people had both
left, actually a sea bass in
particular.
So David asked me if he could
take Flow 21, and I said sure.
So a few weeks later he called
up to say that he'd fixed Flow
21.
It was working.
And I said, well, you're
interested in Flow 22.
And he said yes.
And I said, well, thing about
Flow 22 is it's got all these
analytic transformations and the
huge, very, very complicated
formulas.
We need to have some independent
checking of this.
I said, so are you willing to
try to work out all the formulas
separately from me?
He agreed to do that.
And then we had a meeting and
came to New York and 1st his
formulas looked different from
mine, but then we found they
were equivalent.
So I gave him Flo 22 and took it
back with him to Cornell.
Called up a week later to say,
well, he'd fixed that too, and
turned out that I had got a
miscount on reading plane by
plane off the disk and writing
updates back onto the disk.
But he fixed that and the code
worked.
So Flow 22 was really the first
computer programme that could
calculate transonic flow
solutions for wings with
reasonable accuracy.
Those days it took about several
hours to run a calculation on a
Contravenator 6600, but Douglas
says attributed a cost of about
$3000 for each run.
But they started running it
about five times a day when they
were using it to trying to
design the C-17 wing and things
like that.
And then Canada was trying to
develop what became the Canada,
what do you call it?
Well, now it's bombarded, but
the regional jet and they wanted
to use Flow 22, but they found a
consulting company in Los
Angeles who was running Flow 22
for them.
And this Canada regional jet was
the first commercial aircraft
that had a supercritical wing.
They see the design of using
Flow 22 and eventually NASA kind
of released listing of the code
on some NASA website and it
wound up being picked up by the
Russians and the Chinese and
everybody.
So the other thing that kind of
unusual about my girls, right?
I was a professor now normally
of computer science, the Quran
Institute, but I didn't have any
students, you know, the people,
the students all wanted to work
with the famous professors like
Peter Lacks or Huey Nehrenberg
or Jack Schwartz.
You know, we had ten members of
the National Academy of Sciences
at the Croyde Institute.
So I had no students.
So the only way to continue is
to go on writing the programmes
myself.
And I had this collaboration
that developed with David Coe
and then we managed to get
support from the Office of Naval
Research to go pursue this
further.
So I realised that we couldn't
really use analytical
transformations to do anything
more complicated than a winged
fuse large.
So we, David and I developed
what we call the finite volume
method for transonic potential
for it was really a finite
element method with try linear
isoparametric elements, but I
didn't know that at the time.
And then I got into the going to
the Euler equations kind of
again by sort of circuitous
rooted.
I went to various international
meetings those days, something
called Symposium Transonicum 2
that was held in Gerdingham at
that time.
There was a Wolfgang Schmidt who
was a rather charismatic
character who had a small group
doing CFD and Dornier, well,
Dornier was a sort of nothing
much of a company that somehow
survived after the Second World
War, still learned by the
Dornier family, but Afghan.
We are very effective in getting
support from various German
government agencies.
I met him in Girdingham.
In fact, he persuaded me to try
to swim in the town's swimming
pool, which is very embarrassing
to me when it turned out that I
had to rent some kind of bikini
like swimsuit and I was required
to wear the cap on my head.
And the other cap available was
a sort of pink cap with feathers
or something.
Well, Gang turned out to be a A
star Mortimer player and an
expert swimmer and he was.
He kind of forced me into the
pool.
But anyway, a couple of years
later he persuaded me to come
and spend several weeks at
Dawnia.
This is 1979.
And then in while 1979 there was
a workshop in Stockholm which
tried to compare if it's to
solve the Euler equations with
potential flow solutions.
I participated in that.
I saw that nobody had a solver
for the Euler equations that
reached a steady state, and I
felt that it was wrong.
You should be able to get a
steady state.
So in 1980, Wolfgang asked you
to come back and he had a onola
solvent that had been developed
jointly with ART, received at
Dornea, and he wasn't working
all that well.
It was one of the ones that
wouldn't get a steady state that
had been in his Stockholm
workshop.
He asked me if I'd like to look
at it and I said sure.
But I said, look, did she really
want me to do this?
We're going to have to spend
several hours a day trying to do
computer runs and really to pay
for this.
He said don't worry.
So Donia had this IBM 4341 and
they were charging like one
Deutsche mark per seat to be
used second or something like
that.
And Donna was kind of on you.
You sat, They had two men in an
office.
They would sit facing each other
inside each you would sit one.
Each had a desk, but the desks
were pushed against each other
and you were looking at each
other.
And they all call themselves
her, like him and her Fritz.
They didn't use first names And
I showed up and I told Wolfgang
by his first name and they were
all shocked.
But anyway Wolfgang said don't
worry about it.
So I actually looked at their
solver and decided that they got
some series, we could call them
errors.
They had a kind of, it was
implemented what was called the
McCormack scheme, but they had
an additional artificial
viscosity term.
And the way that was
constructed, turned out it was
going to take differences of the
cell volumes if the flow was
uniform in the far field.
And that's just generating big
error term.
And so rewrote the code with the
first step to what became the
James of Spit Turkel scheme in
the next year.
And at the end of the three
weeks, Hofgang got a bill for
250,000 Deutsche Marks for the
computer cost of my visit there.
They see that his problem was
not mine.
This is the point when I had
been approached by both Stanford
and Princeton with Office of
Faculty Positions.
And what had actually happened
was that in the academic world
they valued applied
mathematicians basically and
people like Milton Van Dyken
mortal land on at MIT, they did
all these asymptotic expansions
and things like that, but they
none of them had ever written a
computer programme or had any
interest in that.
And I suddenly discovered that
CFD actually worked quite well.
But the thing was that there was
nobody, not many people around
who knew how to write these
programmes, mostly from NASA,
but none of them had any
teaching experience was I had
been teaching at the Groan
Institute.
So I wound up being offered jobs
by both Stanford and Princeton
and I went out to Stanford and
founded.
They were offering me 42,000
years salary and you couldn't
buy a house there for less than
about $400,000.
And at that time the interest
rate for mortgages is around
13%.
So it turned out that the
$42,000 would just about pay the
interest on the mortgage house.
So I then I got approached by a
direct phone call from the
president of Princeton saying,
well, I'd like to come down and
play squash with him.
I didn't know he was the New
Jersey State squash champion,
but I said OK, and eventually I
took the job in Princeton.
As a result, I went down and
lost to him at squash.
It didn't matter very much, but
but this 1980 was in transition.
So I had got a first cut at this
Euler Savo Donia, but I hadn't
got it yet to converge to a
steady state.
And when I first got to
Princeton, we didn't have a
computer when I convinced that
we had to buy a mini computer
when I would have gone for
digital equipment, but Princeton
was kind of IBM territory.
So we wound up getting an IBM
4341, which is the same machine
as it had it.
Don't have my own.
That had filled a huge room with
cabinets all over the place, you
know, the disk and one cabinet
and so on.
It actually had two megabytes of
memory.
I had access to that from
roughly November, and I couldn't
get this thing to converge to
state.
It would go down to some level
of error around himmatri and
start oscillating.
I thought it was maybe
reflection from the far field
boundary conditions.
That's when I consulted Eli
Tokyo about non reflecting
boundary conditions.
That actually didn't fix the
problem.
Then I tried running it 1st
order accurate and it converged
very well.
So then I saw that I needed to
have but that was not accurate
enough so that I came up with
this idea of you blend force
differences and 2nd differences
of artificial viscosity and use
the force differences as
background.
But in the nearer shock that
causes an oscillation.
So you turn them off and drop to
a locally 1st order accurate
through the shock.
And this is eventually we became
this so-called JST scheme that
got away with a lot.
Yeah.
But actually for me something
else happened around that time.
So I I presented this JST scheme
and by that time I had got a 3D
implementation with Flow 57 at
the AI AA meeting in 1981 in the
summer in Palo Alto I think it
was and nobody paid much
attention.
But then of course the company
started getting my code Flow 57
and they found it worked.
But just about that time, Phil
Rowe came out with his famous
paper with his so-called row
matrix of basically the
character it's based and it's
the work of genius that paper I
so that kind of got the academic
land.
I don't deserve it yourself.
But when I tried coding the Phil
Roe's scheme, I found that it
wasn't really doing any better
than my scheme, but it wasn't
really helpful to to push that.
But what I do find out about
thorough scheme especially you
had this mean value of matrix,
it's called a row matrix and you
found an analytic way of
calculating and then.
So it's a stroke of genius and
turns out that that enables
analysis of other schemes, not
just a row scheme.
If you use this row matrix, you
can actually prove things about
the numerical shock structure,
shock waves, being in a shock
capturing scheme and so on.
So it really opened the way to a
much broader way of looking at
sort of theoretical side of
these schemes that well, I don't
know where you want to go from
there, but so we're in 1980.
So what happened?
Yes, so you would then at that
time at Princeton, one question
I had was the code.
So you mentioned that people
were using the code.
You were, you know that NASA
were using it different
companies and we Fast forward to
now and there are these large
commercial companies, you know,
and SIS Fluent and Siemens and
all these other.
Did you did you think about or,
or maybe this is what's coming
next, the commercialization of
this or was it very much at that
time this idea of the code was
for everybody to use.
It was sort of for the good of
the community.
Well, there are several things
that I think you need to
realize, you see.
We didn't have copyright
protection of computer codes at
that time.
Actually, that was only
established by Bill Gates around
about early 198283.
So there was only no way to
prevent codes being passed
around.
But in fact, of course, if you
wrote a code that worked and
Flow 57 went up, being used by
just about everybody in the
aircraft industry in America,
and then it got, well, Dawnia, I
had it because of course I'd
been working with Forfgang at
Dawnia.
But then I had a consulting
arrangement with Cray Research
and I didn't mention this, but
actually when I wrote 3D code
Flow 57 that was in Kandra
around February, March of 1981,
I could only run a measure of
like 48 by 8 by 8 on this, I bet
4341.
But I had been approached by
Cray Research because we're no
trying to sell their first Cray
One computers.
They got benchmarked typically
by floor 22.
So they decided it might be
better to have me on board.
And I was interested too,
because I thought that this JST
scheme should run Vector without
a problem.
So they gave me access to Cream
One when I first tried to run,
but his code that didn't run
vector.
And I went out there and
discovered that there were one
or two minor changes I still had
to make to the code, but it
would run vector.
But when I tried to write Flow
57, I had a terminal with
Princeton connected to Cray
Research.
So after I got it to run on
4341, I was able to submit the
same code to Cray through this
terminal, and I could run
something like 96 by 16 by 16.
It still wasn't enough memory on
the Cray one at the time, but at
least that was enough to kind of
meaningful calculation.
But now it meant Cray had the
code.
So they were trying to sell
Crays in Europe and they sold
one to the British Royal
Aircraft Establishment and
another to the Dutch in Alaro.
They they threw in Flow 57 as
part of the deal without my
knowledge.
So this kind of got to Holland
and England and well, I didn't
get it money out of it, but I
did get a good deal of
recognition.
And so now my sort of attitude
started to change around there
because the Air Force is pseudo
contract with a request for
proposals to kind of solve more
general configurations in the
obvious thing to do, we go with
some kind of multiple extension
of Flo 57 and bunches of
companies like Lockheed and
Northrop and Sohn all submitted
proposals to the Air Force,
which amounted to further
developing Flow 57.
And seemed to me that the Air
Force could have asked me
whether I wanted to permanently
the code rather than funding
locking what they wound up
doing.
So I was sort of started to
wonder, well, how are we going
to get more control?
But then I also knew that I
wanted to do a complete aircraft
calculation.
And my first idea was that you
could use a multi block mesh.
But then when I looked at how
hard it would be to generate
these meshes, I saw that we
didn't have anybody at Princeton
who was going to do that.
And I had this time had brought
in Tim Baker from England, as
was research scientist working
for me, and he had his friend
Nigel Wetherill who was working
at the Aircraft Research
Establishment in Bedford.
Nigel was interested in spending
six months sort of sabbatical at
Princeton.
The ARA were very worried that
they had developed a multi block
extension of Flow 57 and they
were very worried that Nigel
would bring it with him to
Britson.
Right.
I said no, I I've concluded that
we have a better chance if we go
to an unstructured mesh.
So I told Nigel to forget about
the multi block code.
We were going to see work from
scratch, the triangulated mesh.
When Nigel arrived I asked him
if he could By this time I'd
become aware of this process
called Deloni triangulation and
I asked him if he would try
decoding it.
And he got it to run in two DA
week or two.
So we could do sort of in
principle multiolu and airfoils
and things like that.
But then I had a meeting with
Tim and Nigel.
I said, well, I think we should
try to do a complete aircraft.
And the idea was that Tim could
generate meshes around the
different components, rather
like an overset mesh.
But then we would take the
points from all these meshes,
just a cloud of points, and
triangulate them with only
triangulation, and that would be
our grade.
And meanwhile, I wrote a flow
solver to work on tetrahedral
meshes, and we had an agreement
from Cramer Search that they
would support this project.
But then we finally got a first
version of the code together.
We called it the airplane code.
Turned out that it used the
whole memory of the Quay.
So they put it to the back of
the queue.
And then at the end of the day
they would turn the shut the
machine down and start running
experiments with operating
systems.
So it just didn't run.
So at that point I tried to
contact Millwagon who was the
president of the CEO of Craig
had agreed to support this and
he was out of time, but I got
his number 2.
They agreed to let us come out
and use the machine during
weekends, overnight.
And I also, I had a, because I
was a consultant, I had some
kind of immediate monitor Cray
and he was very angry that I'd
bypassed him and he dismissed me
as a consultant to Cray.
I said, well, we still have
accidental machine.
It turned out it is, I didn't
care about that.
But we went out in actually in
July, we were given the machine
nights during the weekend.
So we spent sort of two nights,
we were up all night.
Two nights in a row came clear
that Nigel's Delaunay
triangulator wasn't working, and
we couldn't really disentangle
exactly why not.
But then Nigel was due to go
back to England and so we
decided to basically to put
everything on hold for a bit.
Tim and I had summer vacations
when I was spending time no near
again, but when we got back in
fall, we concluded that we
couldn't debug Natural's
triangulation because he was
doing some things that are not
well.
He kind of assumed that when you
called a subroutine that some
data values would still be there
when you recall the subroutine.
It's not actually the case in
Fortune.
It depends on somebody's
compiler whether it is or, which
isn't still there.
It was just almost impossible to
figure out exactly what had gone
wrong.
So Tim started overwriting a
Delaunay triangulator.
And finally in November we used
to go out to Cray because also
we couldn't visualize anything.
But Cray had these evidence of
Sutherland terminals where you
could actually take a look at
what the mesh.
Finally in N1 weekend round
about 9:00 in the morning after
you've been up all night, we saw
that we've got a mesh that
seemed to work.
Then Jim and I had to catch a
flight back to Princeton and we
barely caught the flight, but we
were upgraded to 1st class,
having showed up late and got
free drinks.
That wasn't a really good idea.
Then we got to Newark.
I had this junk car that I
looked at the airport and Tim
asked you if I could drive, and
I said I thought so, but he got
to the car and he just passed
out.
I started driving and I
discovered that I just had
double vision, which wasn't
really good to me.
Two New Jersey Turnpike,
basically I could get rid of the
double vision if I took my
glasses off.
But then I decided it was kind
of lucky that we made it back to
Princeton without a crash.
But anyway, we we finally did
get a successful calculation for
a Boeing 747 which we presented
in the Aerospace at Sands
Meeting Arena in January to 6th
that was well at this point A.
Big moment.
Yeah.
But I thought now I have to tell
Princeton that we've got the
code because Tomb has been paid
full time as a research
scientist by of our groundsmith
by Princeton.
And normally that meant that any
code we wrote that probably
belongs to Princeton.
So I approached my department
head at the time and said, well,
I think this code is actually
has potential commercial value
and it's also possible that you
could patent the numerical
scheme.
Well, it turns out that
Princeton had signed some deal
with an outfit, some of the
small companies, to at first
write a refusal for them.
Property rights are really
software developed in Princeton.
And I got a call from somebody.
I thought I was talking to a
somebody from the legal
department inside Princeton, and
I was talking to these people
and I told them those things
that I probably would not have
told them.
I don't know who they were.
OK Anyway, these people said a
form to Tim and me which we
agreed to give them all rights
and perpetuities to the code and
needed derivatives for $1.00 and
two, and I refused to sign it.
So we're not going to agree with
that.
And there really nothing
happened because these people,
we said, look, we've written the
code, but you ought to patent
it.
So that's, and they didn't.
But the meanwhile the code was
kind of in limbo for three
years.
And then the Wrights reverted
Princeton.
And at this point, Tim and I
went back to Princeton and said,
well, look, the only people who
can really commercialised the
code or actually asked because
we can, we can make it work.
So if I had agreed to let us
form a company that we called
ESOP, Aerodynamic Simulation and
Optimization, we would pay 15%
of the proceeds to Princeton.
So then we tried to market the
airplane code, but the thing was
during those three years, that's
when Florence started to get
going with the mesh code.
So really we lost the window and
I, I didn't really want to run a
company where you, I mean,
actually commercial software has
a great deal of an issue of
marketing, isn't it?
And such like I really care
about doing calculations on some
of the schooling fan or
something.
So, but we did, we did make, we
did sell about 5 copies of this
code 1 to Douglas where they
were used it very seriously.
And John Vassman became very
involved in actually he managed
to fix some issues with the code
because it, it was by that time
we had versions of Cray with
four processes and things like
that.
And for some reason this
Delaunay triangulation should
have been sequential when it was
running faster with the
multiprocesses.
And John figured out that what
was happening was that there was
one particular process going on
which was consuming all the
time.
It was.
So what this Delaunay
triangulation, what you do is
you have a triangulation, you
insert one more point and then
you re triangulate in the
vicinity of that point you add.
But Jim had some flags and at
the end of each additional point
he was setting his flags back to
0 through the whole mash and
instead of just in the region
where it had been re
triangulated.
It turned out that that was 90%
of the time the triangulation
was spent resetting these flags
to 0.
And when you removed that, the
code ran in like 40 minutes
instead of 30 hours
triangulated.
But John Rasberg was kind of
responsible when it's coming.
So they he was secured
successfully.
Donald Louglas to to fix the
some of the problems that the MD
11 on the nacelle wing pylon
interaction, things like that.
But at this time, I also came
back to my original first love.
You see, I never thought it's
just a matter of calculating the
flow.
I thought we're trying to find
the best design on actually
going all the way back to 1970.
I wrote a quote called SYN one
same time as flow 1 and SIN one
actually solved the inverse
problem.
We input the crusher
distribution and it finds the
shape, but we've conform a
mapping.
But I'd never given up on this
thought.
But this is where I I went to a
meeting in NASA Langley on flow
control probably in maybe
February 1988, something like
around that time, kind of a sort
of light bulb went up in my
head.
I suddenly realised, oh look,
these people are trying to do
flow control, but actually you
could use the control theory to
do shape vision.
In other words, the control
would be changing the shape of
the boundary.
And I should have known this
because I had all the background
and control theory.
But I think, see when I did
control theory, I always did it
for finite dimensional systems.
This would be, I've said
something by mistake.
I'm not quite sure what's going
on here.
Can you see the pictures still?
I've got a second little picture
of myself.
I don't know why that happened.
Oh.
I can, yeah.
I'm not sure.
I can still see you and hear
you.
You can see me.
Yeah, all good.
Well, anyway, I sort of hit me
that we need you could just use
control theory and well, that's
control of infinite dimensional
systems PDS.
So I knew that Jacques Louis
Leons, this famous French
mathematician who written a
bunch of books on controller
pedes.
So I had to go off and try to
fight my way through some of
this book.
Well, it's very, very difficult.
It's all in civil of space, so
on.
But I got to enough just to
understand that you need to
solve these adjoint equations.
And so I came up with this
aerodynamic design by a control
theory of paper that I wrote,
and later that.
Yeah.
And they did something that I'd
never done before.
Aerodynamic design by control
theory doesn't actually have any
computer programme in it at all.
It just develops a theory of
saying if you did this, it
should work.
All right.
And.
I think I was partly reacting
to, I'd had feedback that people
said I was a good computer
programmer.
And I said, well, OK, I'm going
to show you that there's a
theory here.
I'm going to publish the theory
first.
And I gave it to Steve Orszag,
who was a Princeton at the time,
and we were pretty good friends.
And he was just trying to start
this new journal of scientific
computing.
Because I knew that I felt it
would help him starting the
journal, and I knew that he
would publish it without my
having to fight by way of
arguing with reviewers and so
on.
So that came out, and now nobody
seemed to believe me.
I read presentations in various
places like NASA Langley who got
blank stares, who gave a seminar
at Stanford and just got blank
stares.
So then I had to sit down and
try to program it myself and I
managed to get to work for
transonic potential flow
equation.
I actually first made a
presentation at the Israel an
Oracle conference in I think
1989.
And once I'd written a computer
programme to take work then of
course started to attract
attention and I so that was
became my main focus after about
1989 nineteen 95 or thereabouts.
I eventually.
I I guess that is no, no carry
on, sorry.
Well, I think the basic thing
is, you know, I was basically
trying to solve the problem of a
transonic flow.
I wasn't really basically trying
to develop numerical methods as
such for the real sake.
If you look at a number of the
other people who've been big
contributors in CFG, Philro,
Bran Vanneo and Martin or Stanos
and so on, and none of them were
interested in aircraft actually
they were interested in CFD as
such, whereas to me.
Yes.
I was interested in designing
better aircraft, and in
particular the problem of
transonic flow was kind of
perfect for me because it was a
combination of mathematical
challenge and everything else.
And how much do you think that
your time in industry shaped
that?
You know, you went from
Cambridge then for more than 10
years in industry before you
eventually moved to a pure or
more of a pure academic role in
the in the 70s.
Do you think that industrial
time made you more focus on the
practical challenges rather than
a purely theoretical, you know,
research path?
Well, I think yes, to some
extent.
I mean, I was involved in, I
mean actually I didn't have much
involvement in any particular
designer Grumman, but I was, you
know, I was exposed to what was
going on.
Of course, they were the main
project half drivers.
There was this, the F-14 swing
wings fighting, which I didn't
believe was the best solution
myself, but, but I used to walk
around.
They'd still had draftsman and
drawing boards.
I used to walk around sometimes
where they had the draftsman and
chat with people.
You know, it was a plan for some
kind of government, I think some
kind of regional jet, and the
starting point was to trace the
three of you drawings from the
Canada regional jet or something
like that.
Watch this stuff and doing it.
You.
Know, but I, yeah, I wanted to
have a real Roman designing an
aircraft and odd enough it
finally did happen in a very
direct way when we got to the
Gulfstream G650 which was
designed around about 2006 so
maybe I should mention that to
you so.
Yes, please.
Dating back to, yes, when I was
Douglas was using Flay 22, he
was Presheni was one of the
really outstanding engineer who
kind of climbed the ladder at
Douglas eventually was the
programme manager for MD-95 and
things like that.
And I can't remember the MD 90 I
think it was.
But then he became vice
president of engineering at
Gulfstream and he was
particularly interested.
Well, he developed the G5, but
then early 2000s he was really
interested in developing a, a
supersonic business jet.
He had, they had deals with the
Russians, people like Sequoia
and so on.
But so he actually asked me if I
would consult for Gulfstream and
I said, yeah, but actually I
believe I can help you more with
Transonics and his supersonic
business Jetman.
And then around about 2006, they
decided to launch this G650, and
Press wanted to have a plane
that could fly 7000 nautical
miles at mark .85, but he also
wanted to fly 5000 miles at mark
.9.
And they're having a problem
because they're actually getting
about 3500 miles at mark .9
according to their first efforts
at designing it.
The press sent me an e-mail
saying, well, would I like to
try to to help that or I said
yes.
So I started working with Bob
Mills, who was the aero lead for
the G650 Australian tremendous
guy.
And this interesting because it
really was an example of remote
cooperation.
So I had this wing body shape
optimization code SIM 107 and I
could run.
I had a cluster in my garage in
this house actually.
So I could run these
optimization calculations in a
few hours.
And then I gave him an account
on my cluster and he could pick
up the geometries from I drop
with SIM 107 and he would then
put that geometry into a solver
for the complete aircraft.
And they were using USM 3D so
that, but I could actually come
up with optimised shapes faster
than they could do the analysis
of Gulfstream.
But eventually it took hundreds
of iterations because the
question of course, exactly what
to optimise and what we were
trying to.
Firstly, it was clear that the
original green design was going
nowhere.
So I told, I told him that
that's why don't I just put in
my own wing sections.
I had sort of lots of wing
sections that had developed in
different sort of studies over
there and just start over.
And so he agreed to that.
Then we found that we could get
a wing which basically didn't
have drag rise to about mark .88
and could fly mark .9 if you
came down to a lower lift
coefficient without a real drag
rise or not much.
And essentially the wing was
designed kind of semi
automatically by SIM 107.
It's so there's a picture of the
two of us in I went to the first
high speed wind tunnel test of
this plane.
Yes, Sir, Lang is transonic
facility and the quadrenic
tunnel.
There's a picture on my homepage
that shows the two of us inside
the wind tunnel with the bottle
wheel and plane.
And yes, when we actually did.
That's amazing.
The actual high speed run, this
quadrenic tunnel verified that
our predictions are corrected
and it was a completely new
level of performance when we
were long range business jet at
the time.
So we left something on the
table because I wanted to have a
highly slightly more sweep back
in the wing impression.
He vetoed that because it was
the first plane the Gulfstream
design was going to go fly by
well and he wasn't sure that
they could handle the lateral
stability problems.
If you had more feedback, and I
wouldn't have the same feedback
as you see on a Cessna Citation
10.
And I think we could have taken
it just a little bit further.
That's the one time that I.
That's amazing.
That was.
Designing a plane, basically,
yeah, yeah.
But during that time, do you
think back, you know, when you
were writing the code, you know,
2 megabytes of memory, you could
barely fit something on to then
still within your career,
designing a whole aircraft and
designing 10 in your garage.
Do you appreciate, does it still
amaze you, the development of
code and computers over your
lifetime?
Yeah, well, I think the thing
was I always thought that you
had to look at what's feasible
at any given time, given
computer resources.
In fact, I'm going to tell you
one thing I learned in the
British Army doing opposite
training.
So they told us that in kind of
situation you have to make a
plan, right?
So you said the first thing to
do is to make an appreciation of
the situation.
You know, the enemy has 10,000
troops and you have 100.
So a frontal assault, for
example, is not going to work
whatever, right?
And then you have to, to find a
goal, let's say defeat the
enemy.
But then you do a based on the
appreciation, you might have to
refine the girl for something
that could conceivably succeed.
So you iterate that a few times
and when you arrive at a girl
that's potentially feasible,
then you draw up a plan and you
carry it out.
So I would say that I kind of
applied that kind of thinking.
It was feasible to do 2D
airfoils in 197071 and then by
the time we got to the 1980s,
you could do even 3D Euler
equations.
And of course eventually, but I
had.
So it took about 15 years to get
from 2D airfoil to 3D boiler
solution for whole aircraft, but
very much paced.
We still didn't have enough
memory in 198586 for the full
airplane.
By the time we got to 1990, that
was kind of beginning to be
fixed.
But I mean, I could hardly
imagine the Rachel Fergus, I
mean, this machine that I'm
talking to on it's about I think
32 gigabytes of core memory, TB
solid-state disk.
And it also actually like 100
times faster than the Cray 1
was.
So we're living in a totally
different world.
And now you move on to where do
we go next?
Well, we still then have the
solution to the turbulence.
We have this large area
simulation, for example, and
that still seems to be a late
deal open, still open about how
to set about.
I mean, nowadays you have these
buzzwords like scale, resolving
simulations and so on.
But I don't think anybody can
calculate a flow.
Let's say it was submarine at
rental, some intent on the 9th
in an accurate way.
At the present time when I got
involved partly under due to
pressure from funding agencies
and trying to work on high order
methods in the last 15 years, I
think they can contribute.
But I know that you're very
interested in machine learning
approaches.
I did get to make one stab at
looking at machine learning.
Some work we did just about last
year.
I had to Stanford before I wound
up taking this job at Texas A&M
of the Stanford kind of force me
to return.
But we actually did write a
paper with Jeremy Morton and
Freddie Witherman, who was then
my postdoctor, Michael
Cochendorfer, who was the
faculty at Stanford on machine
learning for trying to control
vortex shedding officer under
the low Reynolds numbers.
And we were using this.
I know of a so-called Koopman
operator and I don't know
whether you're familiar with
that or not.
But what Koopman did was to say
well if you have a a non nano
process, let's say X superscript
n + 1 equals some function of X
or north that's non needed.
Then if you look at all possible
functions of that solution,
so-called G of X, it turns out
that that's if you think of the
update to the solution G when
you do this non needed
operation.
But that's linear in the sense
that if you have a one function
G1 and another one G2, a linear
combination still works.
So what you do is you associate
an infinitely dimensional linear
operator with a finite
dimensional non linear operator.
And then infinitely dimensional
operators might have continuous
spectrum.
But it could be that there might
be an invariant subset where
anything in that subset in the
initial closure subset stays in
the subset.
Sure is non linear updates.
And if you can detect a
invariant subspace, it might
have discrete eigenvalues and
eigenfunctions and that can be
used as a model.
And we think that vortex
shedding is an example of
something where that might
happen.
We did manage to come up with a
control system based on that
that kind of worked and got into
this nips neuro.
Oh yeah.
It has quite a few citations
already, but when I got to Texas
A and MI couldn't find anybody
on the machine learning side to
work with.
And it's sort of by the wayside
it.
Well, I, I do think that
somebody, maybe you will succeed
in developing some kind of giant
neural network that will
probably predict turbulent flows
reasonably well within a few
years.
Maybe not.
While I'm around the trouble,
assuming we'd have some giant
neural network like these large
language models of it could
predict a turbulent separated
flow, then the trouble is you
might not get any understanding
out of it.
I mean, you can run the neural
network and it gives you some
numbers.
It doesn't really give you an
understanding of what's going on
necessarily.
So that's my.
Yes, that is the.
I don't know if you've come
across this, but at least what I
was told and for, yeah, as you
know, one of the dreams for a
lot of these aerospace companies
is digital certification, being
able to actually get a, you
know, the approval to certify.
But you have to understand how
the code and the method has got
to the answer.
And I guess the risk with the
machine learning is it may be
able to get the answer, but if
you don't understand exactly how
it did it.
Then it's probably not going to
be suitable for a certification.
So that still is maybe a
challenge.
I think that's true.
But of course there are.
I mean, there are people like
this, Stephen Branton at Nathan
Goods at University of
Washington, who've made a lot of
mind about detecting PDS based
on just looking at data such
like, but I don't really, well,
I don't know, I'm not too
worried because I think I don't
really feel that I'm going to be
replaced by some kind of neural
network while I'm alive.
Problem with the next generation
to grapple with it.
So what would be your, what
would be maybe your advice?
So if, if somebody now is
listening or watching to this in
their 20s or their 30s or, or
really at any age and we're
going to, you know, wanted to
make an impact in the field of
aeronautics or CFD.
Is there any things that you've
learnt along the way in terms of
your mentality, the way you
approach things?
You, you talked about the
British Army example, but is
there any sort of yeah, advice
you would give to people?
Well, I think really one of the
problems is that there are an
awful lot of people doing
doctoral studies in CFD at the
moment and very hard to stand
out from the crowd.
And I think what I would say is,
in principle, if the crowd is
going one way, you need to go in
a different direction.
But of course, you've got to
find a different direction that
actually works, right.
Because if you go the same
direction as everybody else,
you're going to do the same
thing as everybody else, and
nobody's going to care all that
much.
So the trick is to find a
different direction, which, if
you get it to work, will change
the direction of the field.
But that's not easy.
Maybe.
Yeah.
Well, as matter of luck also
getting into that just I think
in my case I arrived at
shantonic fluid at the moment
when there was a real
opportunity to do something and
have an impact and kind of hard.
Now.
I mean I can tell you that as a
practical problem, we have all
these electric vitae things like
the joby and they have to do a
transition from hovering to
forward flight typically by
tilting their oceans over.
And we're way short of being
able to calculate that by any
numerical method at the present
time.
And seems to me so if that's
somebody could really solve that
problem, we would have a pretty
big impact.
So tackle the hard problems, I
guess you're saying look for the
disruptive ideas, the difficult
problems, and if you can solve
it, you will have an impact.
Rather than taking the easy
incremental work, go for the, go
for the more challenging things
that yeah.
It would also worthwhile,
actually, we're willing to say.
All right.
Well, firstly, of course, you
know, the whole issue of funding
is, I mean a lot of universities
specifically require people to
to bring in money.
Texas, their name, they don't
even have have prizes for people
who bring in more than $1
million of the stuff or the
other.
But The thing is, if you solve a
research problem, then that
basically determines the
funding.
If you were to solve it, why
should they continue to fund it?
All right.
Yeah.
So a lot of people have a sort
of strategy that they never
solve a problem.
They're always light at the end
of the tunnel where you might
begin to solve it and another
couple of beers, you keep on
funding it.
What's amazing is you should go
ahead and solve it and move on
to something else.
But then yeah, the trick there
is all the work I've done that
had maximum impact was never
actually directly funded.
At the time I did it, we didn't
have a grant relevant
tetrahedral mesh solvent for the
Euler equations that we wrote
that airplane code.
We had grants and Nassilagni and
other places.
All right.
Well, it wasn't to do that.
And I didn't have any grant to
do our dynamic design by control
theory.
I got support later on from the
Air Force, but at the time I did
it, it was not funded.
So there's something I think I
learned at Grumman a little bit.
So my general approach at
Grumman was that I always did
whatever they asked me to do,
even if I thought it wasn't
necessary or that useful.
But I could do it fast enough
that I could still spend half
the time, or maybe even more
than half my time doing
something that I thought was
actually going to work.
But I could both so.
That's a good.
I think it's a good tip.
So be be fast so you can do the
other stuff as well.
Yeah, Yeah, exactly.
So in fact, if you look at sort
of young faculty, I mean, what
you should do is, all right,
you, you have a project that's
safe when you've got funding.
But now do that with say half
the time and spend the other
half trying something that's
high risk and way out there.
And if it doesn't work, you
haven't lost anything.
If it does work, more than a big
impact.
Yeah.
No, that's good.
That is very good.
That is, that is good advice.
Well, I am, I want to be
appreciative of your time.
I I really do Thank you so much.
And I think people will be able
to tell that your journey as you
said, I think that was a very
interesting point.
I would argue that if you had
done what you did shifted by
five years, your code may well
have been the fluent, the star
CD of the world.
You know, I think the fact that
you did a lot of your work, I
guess just before the boom in
CFD, but that does not mean that
your codes were not in some ways
massively the, the influence
for, for the practically the
codes that people use today.
So I think probably everybody
who does CFD today, particularly
in the aerospace sector owes a
lot of what they do to what you
did.
And that, you know, I think
everybody should be and, and I'm
sure are very thankful for all
your work.
And of course, all the, I didn't
mention it, but you have
supervised so many students who
have now gone on to be leading
professors and engineers in
their field who I know, who are
appreciative of you.
And probably by the time this
comes out, you will have reached
your 90th birthday.
So I also wanted to say happy
birthday.
Maybe you're not now, but by the
time it comes out, it will be.
So I hope that when people are
listening to this, they will
also say the same thing.
But.
Thank.
Thank you.
One other thing I'm going to
mention, you know, I, I didn't
finally write a book and I'm not
completely satisfied with the
book because it's got an awful
lot of errors of typos and
things like that in it.
Somehow trying to straighten out
later.
I can get the same fonts all
over the place, wound up
introducing mistakes as fast as
trying to correct them.
But still, the book's fairly
comprehensive.
And I, when I look back, Horace
Lamb's Agent Dynamics book, it's
still useful.
You know, it was actually
written in the 19th century.
But if you still some aspects of
aerodynamic theory for at least
for potential flair were all LED
out in Lamb's book.
So whether I've done will
actually have any be of any
interest 100 years from now,
it's not at all clear to me.
But it would be nice if I was
sure, yeah.
I'm sure it will be and I'll put
a link to your It's
computational aerodynamics,
isn't it?
I think that's the book from
Cambridge University Prep.
Yeah, I just got it.
I'll put a link into the.
Regrettable number of kind of
typos and things like that
still, but it's, it does try to
lay out, you know, a kind of
theoretical analysis of CFD
methods, not just practical how
you arrive at schemes.
No, yeah.
Building quite heavily on.
And people should those books,
yeah.
And those books are great for
people to get a whole.
Yeah.
As you say, there's some
textbooks that people read that
influence what they did.
And I'm sure the same is true
for yours.
So yes, I'm.
I'm sure people will be looking
at that in 100 years and all the
other papers that you've.
You will.
Well, thank you again.
Like I said, I really appreciate
it.
And yeah, it was a pleasure, a
pleasure to speak to you all.
Right.
Well, thank you.
I've enjoyed it actually.